this video is sponsored by Squarespace
an all-in-one platform that makes it
easy to make an amazing website
this right here is Apple's new 16 inch
MacBook Pro which packs a bunch of new
changes including a new thermal design
which should theoretically help improve
the performance of the Intel processors
so in this video we're gonna look at a
bunch of things such as fan speed noise
CPU performance maximum clock speeds
thermal throttling graphics performance
and more and we're gonna compare this
new base 16 inch macbook pro compared to
the previous 15 inch base macbook pro
now we will also be testing out the new
16 inch I 9 8 core MacBook Pros but
Apple is only shipping those out next
week so make sure you guys are
subscribed so you don't miss out on
those videos getting into thermal
performance I'm gonna open up into a
power gadget that's gonna let us know
our CPU frequencies and the thermals and
we're gonna use cinema char 20 to not
only benchmark but also to see what our
performance is going to be like now the
processor that's in here the six core is
the same exact processor as with the
last base 15.4 inch model let's hit run
and right away we saw that the CPU went
up to 4.4 gigahertz and now it is
clocking down the previous one in the
fist 15.4 inch macbook pro that only hit
about four point one seven gigahertz so
right off the bat we could see that the
clock speed is actually slightly higher
for the maximum now it did go up to a
hundred degrees pretty much right away
and then it knocked the speed down and
we're roughly halfway through the test
now the previous 15 point 4 inch with
the same CPU inside of here that one ran
at about three point zero five gigahertz
once the system was heated up and once
the fans and the temperatures stabilized
and looks like right now we're getting
close to the under the test and this one
is running at 3.3 to 3.4 gigahertz so it
seems like it's running at roughly 300
to 350 megahertz higher we just finished
off the test with a score of 2632 and
the same exact processor in the 15.4
inch model that one actually got between
2350 to 2,400 as far as scores so we can
see the
yes the same exact processor in the new
16 inch is getting higher performance so
we're just starting up our fifth run of
Cinebench our 20 we wanted to make sure
the laptop gets heat soaked that it's
running consistent and we are seeing
some numbers that are stabilized really
well so in general this CPU can now hit
up to 4.5 gigahertz at the burst when
it's under these loads
compared to 4.17 with the previous model
now as far as consistent frequencies it
jumps between three point two to three
point three gigahertz if the fans are
all the way up it stays mostly at three
point three and at that point the
thermals our temperatures are around 97
degrees and then it'll dip down for just
a few seconds down to three point two
and then the temperatures will go down
to about 94 or 95 so as far as
temperatures this thing is still running
just as hot as it was before and Apple
is definitely trying to maximize the
performance because if we take a look at
the CPU wattage it will go up to 52 once
it cools down a little bit and it's
running up 48 it'll go back up whereas
the actual CPU is rated lower than that
so Apple is trying to get as much
performance as I can out of this machine
and on average the CPU is running at
about 3.29 gigahertz consistently
whereas our previous five runs with the
15.4 inch model that ran a three point
zero six now you can probably already
tell that we would recommend the new 16
inch MacBook Pro but another thing that
we would highly recommend is our sponsor
of the video Squarespace
I've been using Squarespace for many
years now about five now and I've made
websites both from scratch from custom
templates I've tried multiple platforms
and Squarespace is by far my most
recommended method not only is it
incredibly easy to make a great looking
website but you don't have to constantly
be fixing problems or paying other
people to take care of it it just works
and works well that way you can focus on
doing what you love
whether you need a portfolio site
ecommerce blog or anything else they
have got you covered with great
cross-platform designs to choose from
and built in SEO and security tools as
well which make it an amazing value
head to squarespace.com slash Mac stack
for a no credit card required try
and if you sign up you will get 10% off
your first purchase of a website for a
domain so as far as performance our
five-run cinnamons are 20 average is two
thousand five hundred and seventy seven
that means that the new 16 inch macbook
pro is about eight to ten percent faster
with the same exact CPU and that is with
fans that run slower on average about
nine hundred rpm slower so what does
that mean for our actual fan noise so
I'm gonna max out my 15.4 inch MacBook
Pro take a listen to it
you guys might not hear the full
difference because it's compressed
through a little microphone but I'll
give you guys my opinion from what and
what I can actually hear alright so we
just went back and forth many times had
both them on the same time and I even
busted out my Apple watch the decibel
reader and we do have a verdict now the
new 16 inch MacBook Pro is one decibel
louder overall but there is also a
difference in the pitch of the sound the
old 15.4 inch MacBook Pro does have a
higher pitch even though it is quieter
and it's just a little bit more like a
little buzzing type of sound now it's
time to test out Geekbench 5 so we can
see both the single core performance and
multi-core the results are in and we are
seeing about 6 percent higher scores for
single core and about 10 percent higher
scores for the multi-core and let me
remind you that the processors are
exactly identical the only difference is
the larger body and better cooling so I
would say that is definitely a good
improvement for the same price and now
let's get into graphics so we're gonna
test out the metal performance using the
new Radeon 5300 M with 4 gigs of memory
what's really great about these new
graphics cards is that they are now
seven nanometer and Navi designs that
means that it's going to use less
electricity and put out less heat than
the previous graphics while getting
really good performance which we'll see
how they come here here in just a second
and here are the scores we have 21,000
328 which is about 65% higher score than
the previous base 5 5 5 X graphics card
now not only does it absolutely smoked
that graphics card
actually beats out the Vegas 16 graphics
where he had to spend at least three
thousand and fifty dollars to get that
graphics card and it gets close to the
Vega 20 which it had spent three
thousand one hundred and fifty dollars
and this GPU is in the base model and of
course we're just little bit more you
can upgrade to the better version now
let's go ahead and see how this graphics
card will perform in a gaming we're
gonna run Unigine heaven which is a
gaming benchmark and i'll give us a good
reference point of how it compares to
the previous ones alright guys so the
results are in and I am honestly really
surprised so we have a FPS of forty
seven point seven frames per second now
this is the base graphics card that you
get with the base one comparing it to
the previous base that only got 17 point
eight frames per second up to 47 that
means that the new base graphics are
almost three times as fast for gaming
the previous MacBook Pro when the Apple
added the Vega 20 graphics we did a
gaming test and we said that this is the
first MacBook Pro that we can actually
recommend getting for gaming in this new
MacBook Pro with the base graphics
actually games with about 25% higher
frame rates than the Vega 20 which was
the previous best that you have to spend
at least 3,000 150 dollars to get that
graphics card now the base 2400 our
model smokes that as well so I was not
expecting that Wow now do keep in mind
that there is a better graphics card the
5500 M 400 bucks more you can get that
one with four gigs or for $200 more you
can get it for eight gigs or if you buy
it through our link down in the video
description you'll actually get a
hundred bucks off of that so for only
hundred dollars or more you can get
double the video memory and better
performance now we're also going to be
getting a model with that in and we're
gonna do a direct comparison between the
two graphics cards figuring out how much
of a difference there actually is in
multiple different use cases so make
sure you guys are stayed that you guys
stay tuned for that video but overall I
mean I am impressed just looking at the
thermals and looking at the performance
of course there's a lot more differences
such as the speakers microphone keyboard
battery life and we're going to be doing
a side-by-side comparison that's going
to be out tomorrow so make sure you guys
are
subscribe see guys don't miss that we're
even going to take off the bottom casing
and look at the batteries in the layout
there so there's a lot of content to
come
overall what do we learn from this video
well the CPU runs at higher frequency
it stays consistently at roughly 250 300
megahertz higher for all core
performance the fans run slower they are
slightly louder but lower pitched and
the graphics card absolutely demolishes
not only the previous base model but in
some cases it gets close to the best
graphics available very close or beats
it out in like in terms of gaming so
overall I think this is a huge win for
Apple and a huge win for Mac lovers they
guess from watching this when max click
that circle above to subscribe and the
notifications down below and check out
these other two videos or right over
there
and I will see you in next
[Music]